foreign
I spent my whole career in the
non-profit sector Street outreach
program management fundraising Grant
making public policy you name it I've
done it I've seen a lot
and I'm a really positive person so it's
actually difficult to say this but the
way we do philanthropy right now
the way we've done it for decades
is broken
and here's how I found out
in my early 20s I was a Frontline social
worker in New York City working with
people living with HIV
many of them had multiple chronic
illnesses and they were under housed
so I spend my days and even some nights
with them running around the city to
doctors appointments and housing
agencies
the day-to-day work was hard
but the hardest part was we never had
had enough funding to do the work
on Friday mornings I'd go into the
office to write up my case notes for the
week and I'd speed past front reception
not looking at the mailboxes full of
blue slips
each Blue Letter marked another
colleague let go because of our funding
crisis
within one month I'd lost half my team
and my caseload ballooned from 30 to
over a hundred
and this is the reality for so many
non-profits they're at the mercy of
their funders
and when we look at those funders they
decide who and what gets funded
and it's almost always a mystery how
they make those decisions
non-profits spend so much time
fundraising filling out pages and pages
and pages of paperwork
and they're filling out so much
paperwork that they hardly have any time
to actually support communities which is
literally the thing that they're funded
to do after years of doing amazing work
improving every single metric we'd hear
things like I'm sorry our major donor
has switched Direction they're no longer
working and investing in HIV and AIDS or
I'm sorry we issue grants for three
years Max
this would never happen in the private
sector you do an amazing job for three
years and then get fired
it makes no sense
so I decided to switch sides instead of
being on the side that's asking for
money what if I went to the side that
was giving money help them understand
what was happening on the ground and
make a change
so off I went into the world of
philanthropy only to discover that
trillions of dollars are in Donor
advised funds and private foundations
just waiting to be donated
meanwhile
those non-profits and community-led
organizations are wasting so much time
filling out paperwork and competing over
scraps
I'd hear a donor publicly support a
cause like homelessness
and then behind closed doors I'd hear
they don't really know what's good for
them what they really need is
which is code
for donor Knows Best
I was confused How could a donor
possibly know what was really needed
their lifestyle looked nothing like the
people they wanted to help
the problem wasn't a lack of money
again trillions of dollars are sitting
just waiting to be put to work
but even if we unlocked every single one
of those dollars it actually wouldn't
matter because a very small group of
people are making all of the decisions
about funding their priorities their way
almost 70 percent of donations are
directed by the top one percent of
donors
and they choose causes that resonate
with their lives like their University
or the Arts and these issues are over
funded
and look I know that donors have good
intentions I really do
but good intentions are not good enough
communities are being left behind and we
are running out of time
I wanted to shift the power Dynamic from
a top-down approach to a community-led
model where non-profits and donors
really work together
so in 2020
I co-founded the foundation for black
communities with Lee Van abacore Jacob
Lamar and Joseph Smith to do exactly
that
we were inspired by a radically
different type of philanthropy
black philanthropy
it's the formal and informal giving that
happens in Black communities around the
world in some cases it's the kind of
giving that you don't get a tax receipt
for
and I learned this most in my family we
do almost everything together
including box hand
box hand is an informal savings group
and in my family we have 13 members
so twice a month we all throw a hand
meaning we put a hundred dollars into
the pot and one person gets the entire
thing thirteen hundred dollars
the person who gets the full amount
rotates and you'll get the full thing
two times a year
it's helped my family buy a new fridge
pay school tuition and you know what
we've even put a down payment on a house
using this
and sometimes we negotiate
oh you need your hand ahead of me no
problem I'll wait
of the 13 people some really need it
it's their only means of savings
and others would be fine without it but
here we're all equal
there is no top or bottom
it's not about charity or pity or
sympathy
the goal of box hand is that everybody
levels up
and it's easier to level up together
because we're accountable to the
collective
this practice has existed across the
African diaspora since the 1700s
in Guyana we call it box end in Nigeria
it's Susu in Mali and Senegal it's
called and in Jamaica it's partner
and the cool thing is this exists
outside of the African diaspora too it
looks slightly different from place to
place
the Haida nation has pot latches in
Mexico there's tandas and in Cambodia
there's tongtin
and communities turn to each other and
use this kind of collective approach
when we Face exclusion and systemic
racism in the financial industry
for example black people are rejected
business loans and mortgages at twice
the rate of the general population
and so when we face that exclusion we
turn to our communities and are creative
in our solution making
and you know this has been passed down
from generation to generation my mother
taught me this
she gives generously to our communities
because they gave generously to her
now and forever the collective giving
never stops
black philanthropy is rooted in a
concept called Ubuntu
it's an African philosophy widely
understood as Humanity towards others
and we have a saying I am because you
are
or I am because we are
and that means what affects you
affects me
we're all interconnected and have a
shared responsibility to one another
Ubuntu would be the guiding principle
for the foundation for black communities
and in order to do that we need to make
two practical shifts
who is making funding decisions and how
those decisions are made
so the who is obvious we're looking at
black community members but we're
looking for true on the ground experts
and this is an important distinction
some people will say to me Rebecca
you're a block tell us what's best for
black communities
which is actually ridiculous how could I
possibly speak on behalf of all black
people you can't it's not possible
so to have real insight we look for
local experts and let them make the
decisions
because they know their communities
their partners and field the best
and this is what we did in our recent
five hundred thousand dollar youth
Wellness granting program
we received 99 eligible applications
from black groups working in everything
from diabetes awareness to Inner City
farming and after school programming
and just like box hand we turn to the
collective and extended an invitation to
be part of our grant review panel
now the invitation was intentionally put
to anybody connected to the project it
might be a program manager a participant
or a volunteer
and those volunteers became peer
reviewers the peer reviewers read each
application scored them and offered
candid feedback and then we used their
rankings to allocate funding
in other words it was the collective
that made the funding decision
now you might be thinking
what's the big deal about that
but after years in philanthropy I can
tell you that's not how it's typically
done it's usually the donor maybe their
relative or a CEO who has the final say
but here we trusted Community to do the
work
and to make those funding decisions
luckily we're not the first or only to
pool funding and Trust Community to make
decisions
we're part of a growing movement that's
changing the power dynamics in
philanthropy
and recently because of our
community-led approach and Collective
advocacy
the Canadian government awarded the
foundation for black communities a
historic
200 million dollars
this is amazing and I'm hopeful that
private foundations and donors will
follow this powerful example
you know there are hundreds of
community-led collaboratives working in
the most pressing issues of our times
for example there's right relations
collaborative and Indigenous peoples are
making the decisions there at the
equality fund feminists are making the
decisions
and at claima fund climate activists are
making the decisions
when I think back on my time in the
front lines I wonder
if different people were making the
funding decisions with those blue slips
even have existed
because the funding was always available
it just wasn't accessible to the
communities who need it most
and this is finally changing with
community-led collaborative funds
even after all of my time in the sector
the highs and lows I'm optimistic
because the future of philanthropy is
happening right now where community-led
collaboratives are the bridge between
people who want to do good with their
money and the people on the ground with
the experience to do it
this is Ubuntu
we are all interconnected and each of us
has a role to play
I am
because you are
because we are
thank you